joining us right now is the face the
nation moderator and cbs news chief
foreign affairs correspondent margaret
brennan good morning how are you doing
i'm doing well thanks for having me here
at the tv course thank you for joining
us there's a lot to talk about so let's
jump right in over the last few weeks
the biden administration have been
saying that an attack is imminent but we
haven't seen anything yet so question is
are we being played by vladimir putin
that's what everyone's asking what is
his ultimate goal here but we know that
this has to be a decisive weekend if not
for any other reason then the 20th is
when he said the military exercises
would end that's sunday so he's got this
gun cocked and loaded whether he pulls
the trigger or not has been that
question but all the signs on the ground
including just this morning the united
states says he has now upped the number
of personnel to about 190 000 and they
said personnel not just troops uh that's
people at field hospitals but that's
also intelligence assets uh in and
around ukraine so all the pieces are
there so as christina rafini was saying
the signs for diplomacy are there the
sliver of a chance but the state
department also said they'll call off
those talks if ukraine and russia
actually go into a conflict so he said
the signs are there do you mean that the
checklist that vladimir putin is going
down this is what he would be doing
before there would be an invasion and
that's exactly the right way to think
about it according to the u.s officials
that we have spoken to the scenarios
they have played out this looks like
checking the boxes to get to that point
because they are as david martin has
reported actually moving tanks into
attack positions they are actually
carrying out cyber attacks as the us
said today they've been focused on the
banking and defense sectors in ukraine
so that checklist of the things plus the
predicate of creating an incident in the
southeast it looks like he's getting
ready to make that decision so margaret
give us some context here uh part of the
pretext for vladimir putin's
machinations is his claim that he's
repeated over and over again which is
that the united states pledged back in
1990 that they would not expand nato
eastward i think that would mean
including ukraine but that's not really
true he does seem to have a historical
you know he there's something about
ukraine
that he wants explain that to our
viewers well
in terms of moving eastward ukraine as
even president biden said isn't about to
join nato they've been sort of
twisting in the wind since 2008 they
would say and they haven't met the
standard for being admitted so that
hasn't changed in terms of the
provocation that vladimir putin may be
claiming is there but
in terms of how that would matter moving
the borders and this is the nightmare
scenario is getting uh nato troops on
high alert so close in proximity to
russian troops that any errant shot any
you know right turn russian forces could
make could spark a broader conflict but
in terms of the window for negotiation
the united states says these maximalist
positions put them in a really tough
spot because they can't say ukraine you
will never join even though there's no
active process underway to pull them in
to nato so uh that is sort of the
standoff the things that are being
offered are arms control talks other
options we seem to be really focused on
ukraine in a way um obviously you know
the nato forces are seem to be behind
this country but
i'm i'm curious for folks who don't
understand the politics here you know
why wouldn't a better deterrent be
for
vladimir putin to be staring back at a
force
that's that's equally aligned on the
border right well
the us military would say that russia
will have air dominance they will
overwhelm the ukraine forces and
president biden has said he won't send
americans to die for ukraine he will
send them to die potentially for the 30
nato countries that border it which is
why you have that sort of crescent there
and to vlad's argument or suggestion
there i mean the importance here for
russia or vladimir putin based on some
of the public statements is that he
views ukraine essential to like russia's
imperial designs historically he does
not recognize that ukraine has a right
to exist as an independent state and
people yeah the crimea has been fought
over for the last 150 years or so um
the fact that the president of ukraine
is leaving the country to go to munich
what what exactly does that say in terms
of the timing of all of this it's a
fascinating
thing that the munich security
conference is happening in these next
few days every official i've talked to
have said it's not really a good idea
for him to be leaving the country while
he will be embraced by the german
chancellor and the united states vice
president
he is allowing for a potential window
here for action last point i would make
is it's also quite ironic you know
munich historically is thought of
diplomatically as this uh concession
point appeasement
failure in 1938 to stand up to hitler
and tell him to go no further and that
weighs on the minds of europeans who say
we can't appease vladimir putin right
now with saying okay you can have these
small territories here or there they see
it or at least the united states sees it
as the need to defend the entire nato
and western alliance all right margaret
thank you so much and be sure to watch
margaret on face the nation this sunday
when she'll be talking with secretary of
state blinken who says he's trying to
prevent war